i would like to begin
by saying that i am
very grateful
to whoever has been involved in getting
us home from politicians media members
whoever has been
trying very hard to get our voices heard
i'm grateful i also want to begin with
thanking i mean i will not be able to
thank everybody but i want to kind of
categorize my family in the uk who have
been really really supportive my family
in iran who wanted to be speaking up but
the situation in iran is very difficult
you will be under so much pressure that
you will not be able to speaking up for
your own right so they were very much
both scared to talk about it but at the
same time and
willing to do that but thankfully we had
my amazing wonderful
husband to to do the job while you know
we were
kind of worryingly and impatiently
waiting around to see what's going to
happen next
i want to thank all my um
friends as well in iran who supported me
over the past two years and i was under
house arrests
and when i came out of the tag to
entertain me and keep me upbeat
i also want to thank all the medical
team in iran who have been looking after
me it was an amazing experience to see
people who knew me
through media just to be you know
looking after me when i was under house
arrest and when i came out of it just to
give me medical support and you know
advice
i would like to thank
the members of um
prisoners of the family members of
prisoners in iran who i happen to be
very very close
with
um just like um
rossan's
parents and family
who have been
really supporting me all along this
journey i want to thank my
amazing lawyer in iran
he has been accompanying me to the court
and fearlessly fighting for my release
there is very little lawyers in iran can
do
with regards to human rights but i think
he has been just amazing throughout that
journey and
the least but not last my amazing
husband who
has been
tirelessly campaigning for me so thank
you so much and my daughter for being
very very patient with mommy to be
coming home so i am so grateful
i also want to mention one thing and
that is
i believe that the meaning of freedom is
never going to be complete until such
time that um all of us who are unjustly
um you know detained in iran are
reunited with our families to begin with
murad but also the other jewel nationals
you know members of the um uh
like religious groups or prisoners of
conscience who are i mean we do realize
that if i have been in prison for six
years there are so many other people we
don't know their names who have been you
know suffering in prison in iran so i i
think
the justice in iran does not
have any meaning because in worst case
scenario you are you know being given
um
the the unfair trial if you're lucky
then you'll be picked up by
by a kind of semi-fair judge but in most
cases you're not being lucky um
the journey back home was tough i ran
with richard said to thank the
uh
foreign secretary i have i do not really
agree with him on that level uh i'm
gonna tell you that because i have seen
five foreign secretaries changed over
the course of six years that is
unprecedented given the politics of the
uk i love you richard respect whatever
you believe but i was told many many
times that oh
we're gonna get you home that never
happened so there was a time that i felt
like you know what i'm like no i'm not
gonna trust you because i've been told
many many times that i'm gonna be taken
home but that never happened i mean how
many foreign secretaries does it take
for someone to come out five
it should have been one of them
eventually so
now here we are what's happened now
should have happened six years ago uh i
think
we all know
this is i'm assuming this is going to be
public knowledge how i came home
i'm not gonna mention i don't know the
details but what took me home now
on the very same day 17th of march 2022
that is the very same day that i left
london
17th of march 2016 to go on a two-week
holiday and i never returned
on the flight that i was coming back
home with but i think it should have
happened exactly six years ago i
shouldn't have been in prison for six
years
um
and um
and yeah i think
i think
we have we have gone through a lot it
has been a tough journey
um
the coming back was also very tough uh
so you you do realize that you know
coming back to a daughter who is nearly
eight
i left her when she was not even two
there was a whole lot to catch up
with richard
and gabrielle and getting to know them
better
so i would appreciate
you know the privacy
and
yeah and thank you very very much i i
think i should really thank
uh the media members because that is how
the world happened to know my story so i
am grateful for that